[Music]
josh is with us in seattle hey josh
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave thanks for having me i'm
excited to be on with you we're honored
to have you how can we help
yeah so i am
actually a second generation uh
following your principles dave financial
success and i'm currently in a spot
where i am really wanting to buy a new
car i'm a natural spender and i've saved
up for it and with the craziness of the
market normally i would buy used but at
the price of the car and based on my
financial situation i'm wondering if
it's okay if i you know i celebrate and
move forward in that way are you a
millionaire
i'm not a millionaire yet then i
wouldn't buy a new car
okay
does the price of the car and the rest
of my financial situation matter though
no because you don't have enough net
worth to absorb the loss of a brand new
vehicle
okay you can buy it if you want to buy
it but i wouldn't
what's the value what car are you
talking about
yeah so it's a ford's new little pickup
truck it's like 22 thousand dollars okay
i've got the cash saved up for it plus
rolling in my my current car's value and
yeah
okay
and and your um
your your income is what
uh my income is about a hundred thousand
dollars a year okay
and uh how old are you
i'm 31.
okay all right so josh i can tell you
what i did uh
my wife
when we needed a new car
and
dave takes care of my family pretty well
and i went and bought a used car
and i did that about three weeks ago and
i walked on and wrote a check for a car
on the car lot down the street here
and
then i drove home and so that's what i'm
doing in my house man just and even if
it was five thousand bucks difference
between a 2018 and a 20 21 whatever the
thing was 20 i don't know what year it
was
even if it is 3 000 500 i'm not gonna
give him that money not on a car like
that okay here's the thing the way
you're structuring your sentences and
the way you've asked the question
tells me you have a really bad case of
car fever
you are really sucked in and in love
with this little truck
you have bought it you have driven it
you fantasized over it and now you're
rationalizing the purchase of it it's
going to give you muscles your hair is
going to grow back all the things you
know it's you know it's going to make
you sexy it's going to do all this and
it's just none of this is true it's a
stupid little truck
and they all go down in value
and you can do whatever you want to do
josh you're a grown man okay but you
called and asked me
the rule of thumb that i've used for 30
years and it's served me well is don't
buy
a brand new
vehicle
because vehicles go down in value unless
you have a huge net worth
and the ability to accept the loss of
value
well with covid in the crazy car market
and i know
but they're going to go down in value
they're not going up
five years from now things gonna be
worth nothing
and ten years from now it's gonna be
worth double nothing
and that's what they do that's what all
of them do
and so you just decide how much of that
you want to absorb
and
it's probably not going to cause you to
go bankrupt it's probably not going to
hold you back that much
but it is a good rule of thumb to not
buy the largest thing we all buy that
goes down in value uh to buy the worst
possible scenario of it going down in
value which is brand new um unless
you've got a large net worth to absorb
it it's that simple it's not a principle
it's just i just
i just did it it's arithmetic and so you
but you can do whatever you want son
it's okay i mean we'll still be friends
but i wouldn't advise